climate reparations do you guys see this  yeah a billion was a billion dollars I  think so and uh a lot of people on the  right missed the point they come out and  they say this this climate change stuff  is bunk and the you know oh and Joe  Biden's giving away our money  you know why he did it  the concern right now is that the brics  nations are expanding the world economic  foreign  people like Joe Biden want the Petro  dollar to remain in the future  how do you maintain the Petro dollar  you give the money to people and tell  them you say I'm gonna give you money  then guess what happens these people say  I have this money it's valuable you give  to other countries you give it to  Pakistan for gender studies then brick  says hey hey use the ruble or the or the  one and they go no no I have all these  dollars they're valuable  by giving out this money  the US is trying to force other  countries to use the dollar and retain  it and maintain confidence in it